so we actually have a good 45 minutes
for discussion and I thought I would
just try to raise a couple of things
that might unite or bring together a set
of conversations between the panelists
before we then actually open the floor
to discussion and I should just know
Smitha that Geylang but when she was
commenting on the first Monday said this
first set of Mundell debates proposed
precisely the idea of proportional
representation along the lines of cast
and made the argument that this that
this kind of false dichotomy between 50%
of those who belong to the domain of
merit and 50 who are coming in through
the the reservations policy is actually
a flawed logic that produces resentment
and we actually need to have
proportional representation all down the
line but three sort of broad questions
that I thought maybe either the
panelists could sort of converse with
each other about or might be sort of
broad arcs that that bring all of the
papers together one I was especially
struck by the fact that all of the
papers actually asked what the archive
of the little life and after that labor
might be and so what actually
constitutes this this archive of Dalit
suffering of the pain on the one hand
but also of of the voice so to speak so
we go from you know the UN and some of
the most fundamental set of documents
that produce an investment in political
humanity all the way to the literary to
the testimonial to laws themselves into
law cases themselves as reflecting
something about the life worlds of the
lips today and so I'm especially struck
by the the range of sort of materials
that each of you is using in
constructing what I would call a kind of
archive of gendered Deluth life and a
flavor and here there are a lot of sort
of dichotomies or binarism 'z that
between voice and body right so
testifying to violence on the one hand
and then the kind of burden body of the
Dalit woman
Sudan but Raja both prata the difference
between silence and stigma and so a
whole set of sort of dichotomies around
at the one hand the politics of voice
and then the visibility or the
invisibility of the developed body and
there's something quite interesting
happening in the relationship between
these two and I think all of you bring
this up in in the forms of activism that
you speak about and of political
organization the second I think is the
question of what is happening to gender
through caste and again I'm struck by
the fact not merely with Smith s
argument that you know gender is indeed
not about women but it is about the
fundamental organization of notions of
femininity of masculinity of domesticity
of intimacy and so forth all the way
through two questions that I think Sudan
and Raja also brought up which is that
there is something very complicated
that's happening in the relationship
between the little men and Dalit women
but also in the manner in which that if
men are themselves implicated as it were
a kind of node both in the reproduction
of caste specific patriarchy but as
themselves emasculated I think roach as
the term you used within a broader set
of Brahminical order a kind of hegemonic
order of caste patriarchy and so what is
it that's actually happening to gender
through being able to think about cost
and and I'm very interested in this for
two reasons I mean one of course you
know what is it that's happening to
gender through caste
how can we take down the kind of
monolithic constructions of gender and
of feminist activism that have come to
us from the 70s I think is so there was
mentioning within the context of the
Indian feminist movement but I'm also
struck by the fact that the people that
anti caste and Delhi feminists
constantly referenced are not feminists
or they're not women there are people
like Ambedkar they're people like fool a
there are people like Betty earth who in
some ways launched some of the most
profound critiques at the relationship
between sexuality and sexual
subordination and the social
reproduction of the caste order as a
socio-economic system and so there's a
way in which questions of caste labour
caste stigma and a sexual labor of women
were brought together I think
profoundly in in that the writing and
the thinking of some of these people so
I'm again interested in you know what
that says about how we understand the
relationship between gender and cost and
then just lastly I'll just briefly end
by noting this question of sort of
activism and the kind of futures that
are being imagined for that politics but
also the manner in which that politics
might actually produce a profound
transformation of the Indian social
whether it be from the local and Raja
you know the persistence of the caste
panchayat and those forms of discipline
coexisting with Smythe's you know turn
to un and to a broader kind of human
rights regime and so as costs goes
global cost also seems to be becoming
profoundly local and so indeed what
we're seeing today is a kind of new
dimension of conflict between OBCs and
Dalits the Caird logic is that took
place in 2006 I think was a very
important illustration of that of the
kind of new contradictions that have
emerged precisely along those new fault
lines but I think also the kinds of ways
in which that leadership the Dalit
leadership today is itself implicated in
not being responsive to some of these
very important questions of sexual
violence and the sexual defilement of
the women and that happened very much in
Caitlyn GI know with the rpi and some of
the important members of the bit of
leadership there so so what is the kind
of new relationships between the local
and the global that are also being
produced precisely by these forms of
activism I would like to reflect on one
inspector more importantly Dalit women
issues and the mainstream feminist
movement this is what you know disturbs
me for several reasons that during anti
Mandela's station women were in
precision in taking processions against
the Mindil Commission the dominant caste
women find
I'll start rather with the Hindu code
bill where you know Ambedkar was talking
about rights for women they write to
about this thing you know adoption
property rights move importantly the
property rights which we are talking
about still today and you know when he
promulgated this progressive loss and I
tried to qualify him into them into a
Hindu code bill the dominant caste women
belonging to Jan Morcha staged a protest
outside the Parliament against Ambedkar
raising slogans against Ambedkar so
since then till today
Carolyn G also Wendell effeminate are
being raped the dominant caste women are
seeing that scene and supporting their
men so how to understand this action of
the dominant caste women never in any
feminist struggles are the women's
movement till today they are talking
about 33 percent reservations in
Parliament but why they failed to voice
the voices of Dalit women they that has
never been an agenda in the women's
movement so far this has been raised by
the Dalit women themselves they are
asking that proportionate reservations
in the 33 again in the quota so wait we
failed to learn lessons like you know
why women have been considered as in
homogeneous category not in
heterogeneity is not addressed by the
women's movement the main mainstream
women's moment so I think it's time to
explore the internal dynamics of the
dominant caste women's movement it's
been failing to incorporate the masses
into their struggle you know what's
going on
let us exploring this moment and the
women should address these questions the
women's movement these questions in
locally as well as globally so then only
we can draw some clear-cut lines that
you know incorporating the Della Femina
shoes and because Dalit women cannot be
left alone they cannot be left alone to
their struggles they need a concert
action they need the consolidator of the
larger democratic forces to wage a fight
because the problems are many the issues
are many and the struggle is still on so
let us explore this you know why this
gender aspects are failing to
incorporate them major the masses of the
population one thing and the second
issue which I am going to talk about
this Dalit women unlike the dominant
caste women they're always not
articulating the feminist kind of lines
sometimes they talk that as they're part
of the adult men because their problems
are similar they are delyth women but
they're Dalits victimized by the
dominant caste people so their issue of
land they struggle for wages they
struggle for their self-respect is
similar on the lines of their Deluth men
they have nothing problems in not many
problems with their men because they had
to fight at three friends as I was
talking about at society and the family
comes very least to them because there
is no inequality in the families their
families the both work out said the both
fight in the boat you know equally they
go out and earn wages in the come home
okay the problem of patriarchal
dominance because of sanskritization is
still there but that's never been a
major issue for delyth women so far as
long as their struggle for livelihood
land and other issues are concerned so
they equate themselves along with the
men they fight along with her men in
several fronts and the issue of
patriarchy comes sometimes in the
literary expressions of the educated
delicate women I have narrated a poem
where it's written by professor it's
it's written by some of the women who
are again influenced by the dominant
mainstream feminist kind of a thing
questioning I'm not saying that it's not
there the discrimination is still there
and when it comes to them putting women
into the forefront in the leadership of
the struggles we may not dare in the
struggle says
Smitha was talking but there never been
a lot as leaders this is a question
again put forth to the Dalit the
movements the Lichtman should address
this why half of the population is still
not is given the space enough space in
the leadership these are the two issues
which we should concentrate yeah just to
piggyback on what Ronnie is saying um I
think before we can even start
negotiating issues like you know caste
and gender and why aren't like men
involved in these things it is very
important point and Ronnie points out
that we are still dealing with
segregation in every front and we are
looking at segregated feminist movements
and that's a huge problem for us you
know especially for the neat women who
are looking to to be self-sufficient and
to create changes within their
communities for themselves for their
children I actually had the privilege of
meeting with a group of jogini women
near chinnough chinnough chatter
Menander Pradesh and you know I was
looking as it was you know approaching
these women my mind was like you know
really dealing with all kinds of
questions you know how am I gonna speak
to them what am I gonna say but I never
said a word believe it you know the next
few weeks did I spend that it was like
you know they had a lot to say and one
of the things was that we really want to
stop this vicious cycle of oppression I
don't want this work to be passed on to
my daughter I don't want her to be
dedicated I said you know as a joke any
person woman and they were very clear
about the fact that I'm saving money for
my daughter's education
but the stigma is there when the girl
child goes to school with the upper
caste children the the main forces of
oppression for that daughter is it comes
from the mothers of these upper caste
children that they shouldn't you know
have anything to do with her so how do
we actually very even begin to
deconstruct these you know these deeply
entrenched notions that people have and
you know let alone talking about men
getting involved how do we get women
solidarity you know around the
you I mean even here I mean how many men
openly declare their feminists you know
it's kind of like an embarrassing thing
for some for some men at least and I
teach Women's Studies classes and and
I'm lucky if I get one boy you know
gentlemen registered in a class of forty
students and it's exciting but you know
so we're still dealing with these things
even in progressive culture such as this
I mean susan b anthony lived not too
long ago and and we are still fighting
for women's rights here so there are a
lot of parallels we can draw but when we
talk about caste and gender it is so
deeply interested entrance because it is
rooted in religion in in and it's always
been swept under the carpet as a
religious issue so it's it's a very
tricky dance we need to play with that i
think maybe i'll focus just very briefly
on the issue of violence if i can and
just because to come back to carol angie
and and other examples that were raised
you know if you if you undertook an
exercise of just gathering all the the
english dailies in india and you read
the headlines of each one of them over
the course of a week i can i can pretty
much guarantee that there will be a
number of headlines that you'll find
about atrocities against well it's in
those newspapers and atrocities that
that truly live up to the term atrocity
and we've we've heard about some of them
they don't bear repeating what's common
about all of these stories are as it's
been said the ways in which women are
targeted as a collective punishment for
the community the ways in which the the
the punishment for the crime of
asserting some kind of pushing beyond
the caste system status quo is meted out
on bail at women's bodies in a way that
sends a message to the broader community
and and you'll also find that many times
and they have a very futile very you
know so that the ways that the violence
is carried out is um is appalling to
read about yet it makes headlines every
single day
Carol angie had some characteristics
that made it into a real national issue
but I just wanted to
it actually wasn't a unique issue it
wasn't an an anomaly it was it was a
anomaly only because it broke with what
I see as complete collective unconscious
unconsciousness about violence in India
there is a way in which it has been
completely normalized that we all open
the newspapers and drink coffee in the
morning or chai and read about it in a
way that does not stir the conscience
and what I think Ganju how it was
different is that it actually started a
conversation so the other thing that
you'll read when you even as you're
reading the same same newspapers you'll
also read about the latecha tations
you'll read about approaching the state
structures getting the National Human
Rights Commission involved bringing
public interest litigation to the
Supreme Court calling on UN bodies to
intervene so even as the violence is
going on and it's a response to engaging
those structures there is also a
narrative of resilience that you can see
in the newspapers it's it's both a story
of resilience and retaliation where I
see the disconnect and where I think
that a lot of the work still needs to be
done is recapturing the consciousness in
favor of recognizing the kind of the
appalling and unconscionable nature of
the violence which has become so
normalized and especially atrocities
against women which have just become so
normalized any one of those stories
taken out of the Indian context or the
context of a caste affected country even
put into and put into another country
would would be I would imagine a
rallying cry nationally yet it has
become so part of the oxygen of the
country that I think that's where the
real work needs to be done is to break
out of that unconsciousness I'm gonna
open the floor I think for for
discussion and again will I I hope all
if you are okay if we collect about
three or four questions so that you know
just in the interest of having people
ask the maximal number of questions that
you can all then take some time to
respond to please be brief with your
questions that have very targeted and
focused questions I know tsukkomi had a
question I think you guys had one and
then I see a couple of other hands here
so I'll have these two and then I I see
two hands over here so in the interest
of
presenting the room and then we'll open
up for further questions please yeah
thought-provoking but having recognized
Dalit women problems are quite unique
and different than others how are we
going to address that's what we have
been expecting because similar
conferences are being held here in after
year but we have not progressed one step
ahead one thing we have been always
talking about in comparison with men
they have this rights they don't have it
ok the other women they have it the
Dalits don't have it but having
identified the strengths and weaknesses
of Dalit women why don't we think little
positive and creative for example all
the women women's general as well as
tell it
they have always negative approach they
always fight about anti dowry of course
it's positive but everything against
anti dowry anti infanticide anti fighter
side and anti atrocities everything and
they but we don't ask we don't ascertain
so why don't we propose para-olympic for
rural women especially Dalit women and
how are we going to change their pains
into gains because after all they have
with students so long and I'm sure they
have the moral as well as the physical
capabilities that can be best utilized
and why don't we ask land and take land
because we don't even say we ask we take
it and we give it I think that's because
revolutionary violence we don't ask we
take it we give it so this is one
secondly we provide employment to each
household one lady so we just we are
just dreaming about it so we create
three
but that women and other women and
because you have a separate agenda for
that women you have separate agenda for
other women then we both grow together
after all because you have been relating
to gender and caste if women want they
can change the world I hope you
understand what it is we can make the
world colorful colorless it's really
need to change a lot thank you I will
request ya all of you to have a pointed
question just so that we can collect as
many as we can I will just add to the
events and then I will make a small
comment on that and there are questions
just a question just so that we can have
as many questions yes sir
as I mentioned earlier that in the last
20 years we brought many recommendations
of United Nations Committee and they
give many judgments on eradication of
the systems to the child labor bonded
labor women's issues atrocities
everything now recent happenings are
extremely important which spital Narula
and I admire her work are extremely
important for India and the Indian men
and women both I had a meeting with her
on that issues privately and she was
very receptive so these the first time
some developments are taking place as a
breakthrough but looking at the stand of
India which we have faced from 1996
understand so you will understand the
question better they so it looks like
they it is very difficult to move the
India can we look into getting the
sanctions against India on these kinds
of atrocities which India will has to
stop it or some sanctions have to be
imposed thank you there was a question
in back and then will allow you to
respond I wondered this is a question
about the state and the role of the
state cos Smith I made a very important
point that the state and India's doesn't
stand outside the caste hierarchy is a
continuation of its own
in words in Bihar there aren't cast
militias someone who's working for heart
ask me why isn't there that in Tamil
Nadu
it's because in Tamil that they have the
police the police function as a caste
militia and this is comes across clearly
and Smith this world and also initiative
custodial rape of women especially the
other one
that's one hand at the other hand the
state puts a lot of effort and money
into women's lending schemes
you know women's this woman's that and
is a foreign scholar that the you know
the prescribed topics are caste minority
religions conversion fry teria gender
gender is not one of the topics that's
prescribed so there's that on one hand a
commitment of the state - you know
implementing a serve internationalist
NGO
Pro you know gender feminist agenda and
at the same time the the the the state
functions as a continuation of caste so
how do you how do you interpret those
that that distinction or that
contradiction within the state and we've
got one question there in in back and
then I'll allow all of YouTube to
respond and then we can start another
round again thank you Chris Queen
Harvard University is it incumbent on us
scholars to present some successes along
with the complaints and the concerns and
I wonder if you I'd like the panel to
comment on the event which occurred in
Nagpur another Nagpur story just a few
years ago when a number of victims of a
serial rapist burst into the High Court
in Nagpur and executed the perpetrator
on the stand because he had been
repeatedly incarcerated but then
released after very short periods of
time
is this really a victory for us it is
civil disobedience of course another
case would be perhaps the career of
honourable Sula kookaburra who became
the what a resource Commissioner for my
rostra and fought for Delic women and
people from that high position within
the state some time for the for the
participants to respond the panelists to
respond
well they said of the contradictions in
terms of state policy but I think also
two sets of questions of what is the
imagination in a sense for the future a
positive future maybe one in Bali
revolutionary violence I don't know I
think I would like to start addressing
civic Ami's question she's a fabulous
writer but if you haven't read her she's
amazing
I read her on and I he just describes in
detail the suffering of the elite women
so thank you mrs. Zhivago me for doing
that for us um in terms of dreaming
dreams for the elite women how can we
like break this this whole cycle of
violence and atrocity and injustice I
mean look at what people like Smith have
been able to accomplish I mean she was
18 I think when she got involved in this
whole issue and you know in her journey
of getting mad and being a mom all of
that in addition to all of that she's
really given the issue international
visibility and if you know if one
singular woman could actually do that
there's a lot we can all do it together
but I always embarrass her because her
documentation broken people which was
published by Human Rights Watch when she
worked with them it's just it's one of
the first documentation ever of
atrocities against Dalits
and you know specifically Dalit women so
that was a serious start for change and
providing that visibility to the
international community has led to what
you mentioned as international
intervention in villages in India which
is amazing what can happen with policy
changes and you know having all these
high connections that Smitha has but
also what is happening simultaneously is
definitely there is change happening in
grassroots among grassroots movements in
India and we all know that you know
leaders of those grassroots movements
are done eat women and you know and they
just have these ways of you know nuances
of actually trying to even dance around
the the connives conniving nature of the
government around and because I met a
group of women where they form the
Sangam right it's like a pool of money
that they have
to to kind of support themselves when
they are in need and the government only
allows certain number of Sangams you
know in a certain you know community so
they have devised a way of you know
actually trying to divide themselves and
represent themselves as from different
villages even though they were from the
same village because they wanted have
like 35 you know little self-help groups
within the community so they find their
ways they have their own ways of
resistance and rebellion and doing it
and in one particular village that I was
in I wish I had videotaped that entire
episode where there was a conversation
going on between you know do the women
their need buffaloes or shall be
established a cooperative you know where
they can actually grind their own spice
powders and then market it to the
neighboring markets and that argument
went on for a long time at least two to
three hours the argument went and
finally it was decided that they will
have a cooperator where they will be
able to grind their own spices and
market it to to the local markets and
that's what is happening now and again
it's only the elite women who are
getting involved in that who are
actually grinding the spices and doing
it so it needs a little bit of an
external intervention but the the
mobilisation the the energy the desire
for that change comes from within that
community it's just a small example I'm
giving but there are several grassroots
movements that are led by the elite
women and changes are happening but it
will take you know several years for
that to actually you know be a
widespread phenomenon but it is
happening so at least you know there is
some light at the end of the tunnel
brief intervention I would like to make
Civic amines question again there are
attempts of Dalit women who are
transforming their anger into hesitation
and pain into struggle I've cited two
examples of Antioch moment and
motherland strength Antioch is a
classical example of and how they lit
women if they want to can intervene into
the and can question the state can
contest the state also and influence
there like you know there
station transformed into the downfall of
the government the then-existing
government so that is the power of the
elements struggling and but what the
government promised again it could not
keep up its promise and again it
introduced the liquor into the market so
that's the irony and next is a
motherland struggle where the women they
didn't allow their men to come into the
struggle they say that you know fearing
that the radius will they'll beat the
men so they themself want informed into
an association they went to the land
government land and cultivated started
cultivating it so here also the state
was backing the money to people
landlords and they were supporting the
landlord's not the Dalit women and in
tuned or case also when the tuned over
victims are shouting for help
the Dalit woman shouting for help to the
police they said what you have you don't
have any single penny into your hands
but if we back the readies they'll give
us bundles of money this is exact the
answer of one of the constable given to
the delyth women see the irony is that
the state the police and everything the
existing machinery is not ready to
support the struggling the little men
and how much they try to transform the
leg lives but when the supporting
systems are not there so they can't
withstand their struggle this is one one
of the point like you know there are
cases where they know that women
attempted to transform the society
attempted to transfer their own lives
but unfortunately it's not been figured
in the mainstream writings also their
struggle is not well documented and as
well as this state support is also not
given to the Deluth women that's one
thing outlet
thank you typically I am Raja always has
a way of rendering me speechless so
thank you very much one of the things
I'll say is that you know the the reason
why I was able to play a role in human
rights watch was able to play a role in
internationalizing the issue is because
of the the work that was already been
being done in the country by the live
activists who have had been waiting for
a very very long time for the
international community to wake up and
notice and also by Belet activist
outside in other in in the Diaspora I
think that the tension that that always
exists is is you want to name the
problem so you want to lay bare the
narrative of the violence but you don't
in the process want to depict a
perpetual state of victimhood and and
the challenge then coming back to your
question becomes how do you put out
these narratives about violence -
because exposure is necessary there is
still it is diminished but there is
still the perception of India as the
world's largest democracy as a very
successful affirmative action and
constitutional project that needs to be
defied and undermined but beyond that
then the prescription turns to making
demands on the state and going to
Nathaniel's point that the state itself
is not really necessarily where
salvation lies even the hague
international conference on though that
women i have their statement in front of
me they're asking for enactment of
domestic violence legislation for
registration of land in the name of the
earth women for interestingly for
education programs on caste
sensitization and elimination of caste
discrimination
it's the demand is always to the state
to please deliver something and that's
the limitation of human rights law and I
think what you're turning to is the much
much more important project of actually
claiming but also naming the civil
disobedience that goes on every day and
it's it's an act every day for an adult
child sitting in the front of a
classroom is an act of civil
disobedience getting up and wearing
certain clothing and crossing a village
line breathing drinking tea from a
separate team those are all acts of
civil disobedience and those need to be
now I think memorialized as much as as
much as the violence has and I think
that's where we need to shift in our
descriptions myself included on the
sanctions point I didn't want to leave
that question out heading sanctions are
I think sanctions have the potential to
send a very powerful message but I'm
always concerned that they end up
hurting the very people that you're
trying to support so that has not been a
strategy that we've taken international
there was one back there - we'll come to
that I just wanted to ask it seems like
just as you know the way the women's
movement has it's you know it doesn't
include Dalit women I also see the
Dalits are very I come from you P from
Lucknow and my avati is our Chief
Minister and she's the most prominent
Dalits woman very powerful woman and I
don't see anyone you know someone of her
position could have done a lot of change
but she seems to be co-opted into you
know making statues of Kanchi ROM and
elephants and what have you I mean I see
her work in Lucknow and there's no there
seems to be no articulation from Andhra
up-2 I don't know how to think of it but
that the Dalit movement itself we keep
using this word as if it's magically
represents everyone and they all
together but I don't see that just
coming from you P thank you
welcome to in a moment yeah good oh hi
my name is Kathleen Thomas I just have a
quick question okay
you spoke about this silence that these
women have I mean it was like horrifying
the stories of how they're really like
forced and terrified into keeping
silence and silent and I was wondering
in your experience where you have
noticed that women have found a safe
space to break this silence and that
it's been successful so thank you
the posing things here but these things
are not held in Kerala do you have an
explanation for that
there's one more question yeah yeah
hello my name is Ravi I think a very
quick question my question is especially
you talked about like purity and
pollution why is rape by Dalit women
perceived differently in Indian society
and what's the man I mean I have a mom I
have a sister I have cousins and believe
you me that's unacceptable where is the
men in this equation all the women on
the panel where are the men so gender
Costin regions so they're kinds of
differences in in what's happening with
the earth activism itself I think there
was a question about silence and safe
havens and maybe related to that what
are the men doing if indeed they ought
to be doing something
you want okay look why are we seeing
such different shapes to see we have the
little women has not reached stage where
you know you can work out for a
concerted action and the coordination
consolidation on All India basis
national route made an attempt but
largely confined to organizing seminars
and symposiums and it's not percolating
to the lives of the ordinary the lit
women that is a major major drawback
which I could see in the lift women's
movement itself this is one of the point
which Dalit women moment need to address
and the issues are local so they're
dealt in local level and the situation
of Andhra may not be similar with the
situation of the UPR any other place one
thing I could see that you know myopathy
coming to my everything it's a political
assertion like I'm seeing my ot as a
symbol of Dalit not Dalit women but a
delyth seeking political power like see
where you know the gender issues we are
talking about may not be figuring in her
major agenda but she's the one who
brought out the statues of Buddha they
be like you know the Forgotten women
hero in of 1857 revolt yeah sorry this
gel carry by del Caribe she is the one
who was guarding Jhansi Rani how many of
them known about her story because she
is the one who was fighting in chances
quota and she she is instrumental in you
know protecting the code and chauncey
fought for some time and you know asking
granny to escape for her life for some
time and the sacrifice of that you know
gel carry by our Buddha they weep an
array and all the statues we could see
there in you P because of my Hatice and
I'm not saying that you know okay they
may be folk tales but there is a truth
also in it and the women symbols
she might have you
to gain the again to come into the
political power and taking the local
figures she wanted as the strategies to
assertion of Dalit power may be that
women power may be a direct women power
she symbolizes again to the power of my
auntie maybe that's true I'm not you
know truly in line with her political
assertion but what I could see is that
an absence of addressing the Dalit women
issues within the Dalit women's movement
also we need to understand that and
there is no concerted effort to make it
at national level we are seeking now at
global level but let us consolidate the
look national level so that you know
everything cannot be romanticized like
you know linking money region to the
other ladies address because the issues
are so important the module is a
struggle like you know the women has to
act immediately they not they they can't
go back to the other people's state
people to ask for support and what they
have done is that they seek the police
help which they could not get then they
seek the help of the leftist parties
they essentia was a leader
P were doubly progressive women's
organization she is the one who
supported them in their struggle so they
they could sort the local support and
could win the struggle so this is how
the Dalit women are making their effort
each single step by step and seeking
their lives were rights for the
livelihoods and for land and for wages
so they are sporadic no doubt but this
while it is up to our economics to make
it into the limelight thank you I guess
I'm speaking to the question on silence
and safe spaces for women
the difficulty with I'm not saying there
are no safe spaces I'll tell you about
one the difficulty with having safe
spaces for women comes from the fact
that political leaders the police force
landowners
work hand in hand with each other so it
becomes very difficult for Dalit women
to go to look for support or to even
like maintain a safe space for
themselves in a specific community but
there is one particular place called
omniversal which is in the district of
pudica tiny Authority in Tamil Nadu
where it is one of the most cost ridden
societies in Tamil Nadu where it has a
history of the presence of RSS and even
currently they have a ashram which
actually trains young people as as RSS
volunteers and so on so it's a it's a
place where you know it has this history
of a very strong presence of caste
patriarchy
now there's one toilet woman who has had
an organization there for over 30 years
now she is fire-and-brimstone I think
those voices are the ones we need to
hear here Joe so next time you organize
this conference we need to bring those
real leaders out here she is fire and
brimstone she had gone through sexual
abuse when she was working the stone
quarry somehow you know managed to
finish her high school education went to
the nearby college couldn't really
finish college due to financial issues
but just decided that you know she was
going to start an organization to
address the same issues that she had
gone through okay so she started this
organization called dr. award which is
for dr. Ambedkar women and children
regeneration and development or
something she has a long title for it
but it is meant to be a safe space for
the elite women but young the little
girls can go there and get legal advice
and legal help and starting small you
know she's now built an international
network for organization and she has
young girls there and stopped working
for her girls who have gone through
sexual abuse who have gone through all
kinds of you know physical mutilation
and things like that as part of you know
violence against women and the
communities so they now work for her and
with her and they are their own moral
and social agents and so that
of women diet women as social agents
becomes her sort of primary goal and
purpose for that organization and such
you know such initiatives are possible
but it takes a long time to build
because she has managed to build that
credibility with the police force with
the political leaders there and so she's
kind of built that safe wall around her
but once that breaks down you know then
it is going to be problematic but she
doubts a bit well because she's really
built that credibility for herself so
there are spaces we've got I think about
six minutes so maybe we can take a
couple of questions and allow our
panelists to use their responses also as
a way to maybe make some final thoughts
whatever you feel either you have not
been able to say or something that you
really would like to reiterate so we'll
do that and bring things to close we
didn't answer this question on catalyst
oh I'll take a stab at I mean there I
think I think that obviously some of the
issues play a play across a little bit
differently across states but I think
that I think it's a myth that it's not
an issue in Kerala and I can I can point
you to some documentaries and
documentation to say that it that it
quite it actually really is so and I
will be happy to talk to you about some
of those sources but I think that that
Kerala is often used as an example to
represent something that I don't think
there's a question here and then there's
a question here in the front so two
brief questions just so that we can give
all of our panelists a chance to wrap up
Thank You professor jianchi I have been
asked I am what I am
VK Chaudhary and have been member of
here wizard for a long time we conducted
this kind of seminar here in Colombia
also and quickly I will not talk about
my organization but I am surprised and I
have question to everybody sitting in
the front that main cause of India
discriminate
is a religion and that point was not
discussed although mrs. Singh brought
that issue
professor Narula brought touch evil and
these are detestable who the sanction
from the God to do it because those gods
have done this to know God all three
guards have a red woman okay so why is a
gender panel not addressing the subject
of religion we're still dealing with the
question of why the Dalit women's
movement is so very different across the
different regions of India yes okay
Alfred seven coming University I have a
different question right okay this is
for Smita given your great experience in
Human Rights Watch and your focus on
human rights law could we go back to
this question that India says look this
is a domestic matter and in all your
experience do you have any insight where
you're probably gonna get most leverage
in the international system in response
to this question
stay away this is a domestic matter if
you can take a minute to make some final
so I think the India's position saying
that this is a domestic matter and it's
accompanied by another position which is
to always say that caste is not race and
therefore it does not belong in the
international community's conversation
and that's a misguided and actually a
misinterpretation of international human
rights law and it's assuming that
various conventions only talk about race
and don't include caste what India has
inadvertently done by doing that is that
it's actually thrown fuel into the fire
and actually created a firestorm on
these issues in a way that has allowed
for conversations to take place
internally and it has it's been on
opinion pages in The Times of India it's
been you know different academics have
been forced to take different positions
so there's a way in which a conversation
about caste in India was forced by the
fact that India had such a recalcitrant
position
ironically if they had wanted it to just
go away they should have just said what
many other countries say to the UN yes
we have a problem thank you for your
help we'll take it and we'll try to work
on it but that's not what they did so
just to point out that that they they
have actually been very helpful to us in
the second in terms of the leverage
points and and this goes back to who are
the different actors I think that there
actually is an Ramaiah who's actually
written about this issue of
globalization as being has talked about
the discontents of globalization or
talked about quite a bit but there is a
way in which the entry of foreign actors
into the indian space and approaching
those foreign actors who do not bring
the caste baggage with them as bringing
affirmative action or diversity or
certain types of conversations about it
inside has been a good leverage point
also the just the bilateral agreements
between the EU and India have been used
as ways to insert human rights language
and I think overall on the international
scene and this goes back to the silence
the question of words their safe space
the international community in a way has
been a safe safe space for though it's
because when you are so marginalized at
home and not heard and where these daily
atrocities we've been talking about gets
so normalized you you have to leave the
scene that you're in and almost reach
outside for it to be even recognized as
an atrocity so even the ability to bear
testimony and to give testimony in front
of international tribunals I don't want
to understate the importance of that and
understate the importance of human
rights as an organizing tool even if on
its own and just having an international
treaty isn't going to do the job the
very ability to be able to use human
rights as a unifying language across
States and across across telleth
activists it's a common language that
transcends cultural linguistic and other
issues that have been used as an
organizing tool with them so to say that
that's actually been and continues to be
a very important part of the movement
including for that women I think we are
at four and I think we're going to have
to wrap up and allow some of the sort of
lingering questions around religion
around a specificity of region and how
this is inflected the nature of the
Dulles feminist movement to maybe take
place
Coffee if any people ask questions for
which you've not received adequate
answers would like to come up our all
the far no I don't think at this point
please come back and speak to our
panelists we have we are very nice
they're very nice and they will be happy
to chat with you it's four o'clock I
welcome all of you to coffee tea outside
and we will ask you all to reconvene at
425 back in this room for the
introduction to the plenary session